en temps normal Mélina plante et
François Daou seraient sur le point de
démarrer leur serre pour la prochaine
saison mais cette année elle restera
plutôt vide les 315 abonnés qui
prenaient leur panier de légumes bio à
la ferme du couple devront
s'approvisionner ailleurs
nous vous écrivons pour vous annoncer
que nous allons prendre une pause pour
la prochaine saison ils ont averti leurs
clients au début février nous ne pouvons
plus continuer comme ça année après
année compléter une saison relève de
l'épreuve un vrai tour de force à la
fois physique et mentale l'image de
celle-ci nous avons l'impression de
tirer une charge trop lourde pour nous
dans leur ferme biologique baptisé les
bontés de la vallée Mélina plante et
François Daou cultivent habituellement
70 variétés de légumes fruits et fines
herbes les deux agriculteurs
travaillaient de 80 à 100 heures par
semaine en été avant d'avoir des enfants
un décider que on avait le goût de
s'occuper d'eux avec la ferme on avait
moins le temps pour ça ils ont réduit la
cadence mais c'est encore trop même avec
quelques employés pour les épauler
tu tombes ou septembre c'est ça devient
dur on termine chaque saison plus à un
stade plus avancé d'épuisement que la
saison précédente et ce travail acharné
ne leur permet pas d'atteindre la
rentabilité
Mélina est la seule à se verser un
salaire l'entreprise est déficitaire
d'année en année on est sa marge de
crédit avant même de recommencer à 16
ans
l'année prochaine ça va être à peu près
pareil que je vais te rendre à 20000
après 15 ans en activité le constat est
brutal on n'a pas trouvé un moyen de
vendre notre production le prix que ça
vaut dans le fond avec toutes les fois
qu'on met leur situation est loin d'être
une exception
selon cette agronome la récolte
salariale des maraîchers biologiques qui
ont une production diversifiée et plutôt
maigre les propriétaires de l'entreprise
souvent ce rémunère très peu ils vont
prendre 10-15-20 000 par année 6 engage
un employé ils ont pas le choix de le
payer au moins ça là minimum donc
généralement souvent on voit les
employés qui sont mieux payés que les
propriétaires de ferme il y en a que ça
va être aussi peu que 5$ 10 plusieurs
producteurs ont décidé d'arrêter la
vente de panier
une grosse production
établi depuis près de 20 ans la ferme la
chouette la pomme a livré ses derniers
paniers bio en 2020 elle avait alors 365
clients
tu dis un jour on va l'atteindre ce
moment-là ou que ça va bien rouler on va
avoir une qualité de vie puis on va
réussir à faire notre salaire ça
demandait tellement de temps pour
réussir à faire le salaire nécessaire
que tu es plus rien d'autre et puis là
ça a rien d'autre dans notre vie
aujourd'hui mère de deux enfants c'est
après une fausse couche en 2018 que
Rachel trepanier a décidé de ralentir le
rythme
j'ai arrêté de faire plus attention
de nouveau enceinte l'année suivante
elle a alors constaté le manque de
soutien pour les femmes qui dirigent de
petites exploitations agricoles la jeune
mère a dû utiliser ses prestations
d'assurance parentale pour payer un
employée qui l'a remplacé pendant son
congé de maternité argent qu'on devrait
prendre pour vivre normalement mais on
la prend puis on la donne à quelqu'un
d'autre qui fera pas 100% de ce qu'on
fait plus de a appris qu'il n'aurait pas
de place en garderie pour la saison
suivante et que la majorité de ses
employés voulaient quitter l'agriculture
s'en était trop mais projeter l'autre
année avec un bambin à la ferme un cheum
qui pourrait peut-être tomber
d'épuisement en pleine saison puis une
équipe composée à trois quarts de
nouveaux personnels
sentais pas que j'allais avoir la force
pour une partie des entreprises là on
est peut-être venu à bout de l'idée de
dire que je vais être un entrepreneur
puis je vais me je me débrouiller tout
seul puis
je vends mes légumes puis et puis tout
va bien aller ça nous ment mais en même
temps c'était tellement fou si on
recommence ce sera pas tout seul environ
170 ferme offre des paniers bio au
Québec plusieurs sont à la recherche
d'un nouveau modèle qui permettra de
gagner sa vie avec une charge de travail
convenable en un an de croissant
d'entreprises parmi nos membres je pense
une quarantaine qui sont des
coopératives de travailleurs ou des
coopératives de solidarité de telle
sorte qui répartissent le risque et le
travail parmi leurs membres qui
travaillent sur la ferme faut pas juste
s'asseoir en temps faut que ça soit
viable pour avoir une belle qualité de
vie il faut que tu divises ta charge
faut le faire à plusieurs plutôt que ça
soit tout sur nos épaules mais dans le
fond l'agriculture notre alimentation ça
devrait être un projet de collectivité
un projet de communauté François dahoux
et Mélina plante rêve d'une ferme
communautaire ou certaines tâches
pourraient être accomplies par les
membres qui payeraient le juste prix
pour leur panier de légumes pourraient
calculer le vrai coût de ce que ça coûte
en incluant nos salaires on se fait un
jardin où on se fait la meilleure
qualité on est aux gens si ça ça de la
valeur pour vous est-ce que vous êtes
prête à partager le prix puis on sait le
divise en tout le monde puis là on va
pouvoir se faire un beau jardin on va le
proposer au monde on a la chance d'avoir
des des abonnés des super bons clients
de longue date ils expliqueront leur
démarche lors d'une rencontre à la fin
du mois cette année on cultive pas des
paniers mais on cultive la communauté la
graine est semée reste à voir si elle va
germer